let's bring in our diplomatic editor
James Bays who's in occupied East
Jerusalem James you have some breaking
news from where you are what's happening
yes uh I I'm by Damascus gate in East
Jerusalem but also an occupied East
Jerusalem the Silvan area we are getting
reports of a shooting we understand that
two settlers have been shot no
information yet on the scale of their
injuries the severity of their injuries
but that's news in the last half hour or
so that two settlers have been shot here
in East Jerusalem adding to a really
tense situation I can tell you that in
the last few minutes we witnessed a
couple of Palestinians who were walking
down here didn't appear to be doing
anything to us at all being snatched by
the Israeli police taken into their
police checkpoint they were then
searched but we saw them being beaten as
they were being searched then moments
later our camera operator was filming
that and a settler came up to him and
pushed him away and you're not allowed
to be here and started pushing at his
camera so just an indication of how
tense it is right now in the in in
Jerusalem in this area after the events
that we've seen in the last 48 hours
after what we saw with regard to the
seven that were killed at the synagogue
in the settlement in East Jerusalem but
also what we saw in Janine that most
deadly attack on Palestinians 10 people
in killing including an elderly woman
killed in that attack the violence is
continuing I'm afraid all the calls were
restraint don't seem to be having the
effect that those who've made the course
in the International Community would
like and the latest incident reported
silwan and two settlers We Believe shot
we're obviously chasing more information
uh from uh the various sources and we
ourselves as soon as we finished talking
to you we're going to go and head a
little bit closer to silwan to find out
what we can okay it certainly sounds
like things are reaching at boiling
point we are getting some pictures in at
the moment these are the latest pictures
of potentially that shooting so we'll
cross back to you with more information
once we get it in the meantime James
where Netanyahu is convening a security
cabinet meeting on Saturday night to
discuss a further response
yes and we don't really know what the
Israeli government are planning at this
stage what we do know is that the police
presence you can perhaps see there are
some police officers just going past me
now that's increased they're they're on
now their highest state of alert and we
understand that Israeli police officers
have all been told now they're working a
12-hour shift what we don't know is what
more the Israeli government's going to
do we know that in the Mount of Olives
at the place where the man the Israeli
police say was responsible for the
attack on the synagogue he was shot dead
at the scene in his car uh there
um the his parents have been questioned
by Israeli police but also other
neighboring Palestinians who'd come to
the house they were arrested 42 in total
arrested there the security cabinet will
meet with Fink in Tel Aviv at the
defense Ministry probably well certainly
after sundown at the end of Shabbat the
end of the Sabbath here for Jews and
what they will do I think is not
entirely clear one factor in all this is
the fact there's a very high profile
visit coming in the coming days and
that's the U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken who will be here on a
pre-planned visit but clearly the
violent situation will be top of his
agenda he's going first to Cairo then in
Jerusalem he's going to meet with prime
minister Netanyahu and other key members
of the new hard-line Israeli government
and also meet members of the Palestinian
Authority we're told so that may in some
way be part of the calculations for the
Israeli security cabinet because they
don't I don't think want to launch huge
Crackdown operations at a time when
there is a visit by such a high-ranking
official and the Israeli and the U.S
Administration position is similar to
that coming from the UN and the entire
International Community they want
restraint by all sides right now
thank you very much James certainly many
moving parts and as we were speaking to
you for your knowledge we are seeing
some what appears to be amateur Vision
maybe phone Vision
um of that scene in silwan and
potentially someone being loaded into an
ambulance that had been either injured
fatally or not so that information is
still coming in
um and we'll give it to you as we get it
all right let's cross to Gaza now where
Imran Khan is standing by for us Imran
what's been the reaction by Palestinians
to that synagogue shooting on Friday
night
well before I answer that question I'm
just going to stop talking for a second
you might well be able to hear uh the
most loudspeakers actually announcing
that incident uh in silwan uh so that's
some reaction coming there uh almost
immediately as we were on air uh from uh
the Moss announcing uh the death of the
two settlers uh via the mosque
loudspeakers
um it's yet to be confirmed like exactly
what they're saying it's all in the
distance but that's the kind of reaction
that we've been seeing uh here in uh the
Gaza Strip uh has a kasim who's a
spokesman for Hamas actually said that
Friday's attack was a response to the
crime committed by the occupational
engineering and a natural response to
the occupation's criminal actions and
that's echoed by all of the Palestinian
factions across uh the Gaza Strip
they've all said pretty much the same
thing also this was a Swift and
Justified response to the events
engineering on tick tock on Instagram on
Facebook on social media a lot of
Palestinians have been showing
solidarity with the occupied West Bank
with occupied East Jerusalem saying good
the Israelis will think twice about
killing Palestinians but with every
single attack with every uh a single
incident that happens in the West Bank
there's fear here in Gaza there's
actually a saying here uh what starts in
the West Bank and the occupied West Bank
actually finishes and guards on what
they mean by that is oftentimes uh the
Gaza Strip becomes a Target because of
the Palestinian factions here and when
the Israelis cross a red line here and
they start bombing not empty targets or
targets they think they can get away
with but uh strategic targets then it's
like what you had for example or Hamas
has to react that means Rockets going as
far as Tel Aviv like we saw in 2021 and
a mass escalation now so far uh no one
has claimed responsibility for this
attack and indeed uh the attacker at
this Street near the center ago had no
Israeli security file on him he was
actually shot dead but there was no
known political affiliations either but
what people here in the Gaza Strip are
worried about that the Israeli
government will come up with a political
affiliation uh perhaps to islamics ahead
perhaps to Hamas and that means that
they will react here in the strip all
right keep us posted as to what happens
on the ground there Imran Khan live for
us in Gaza thank you
moving on now to other world news and
protests have been held upon